the U.S is now just one week away from
potentially running out of money to pay
its bills if a deal is not reached on
the debt ceiling Nicole Killian is
following the negotiations from Capitol
Hill and joins us now for the latest
Nicole good morning hey good morning to
you Dana speaker Kevin McCarthy feels
like progress is being made but there's
still no deal and the house will recess
later today in fact there was quite an
uproar on the house floor when it was
announced that lawmakers could leave for
the Memorial Day Weekend although
members could be called back if there's
an agreement right now the main sticking
point is spending the speaker wants
significant Cuts in exchange for lifting
the debt limit the White House is
willing to freeze current spending
levels but worries deep Cuts could hurt
social programs if Congress doesn't act
by June 1st the U.S government may not
be able to fulfill its obligations that
could cost millions of jobs and delay
benefits like Social Security payments
Medicare Medicaid and food assistance
one of the top three credit agents he's
put the U.S credit rating on negative
watch warning of a potential downgrade
because of all of the political
uncertainty the White House said this is
one more piece of evidence that default
is not an option Tony
I hope it is not Nicole thank you very
much